-For anyone who doesn't know
you are a very big deal
on YouTube.
You have 25 million subscribers,
which is no small thing.
-Thank you. And you're one
-I am one of your subscribers.
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm always
the first to comment.
[ Laughter ]
-First.
-i always write "First."
That's me. That's my tag.
-So creative.
-But you started in 2013,
doing Vine videos.
-I did.
-Can you talk a little bit
about your evolution
from that
to where you are today?
-Well, I got to pour one out
for Vine real quick.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rest in peace.
-We miss you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Six seconds for my short
attention span, man.
-Yeah.
-I love the six-second videos.
-Look, as long as it
got you off the ground,
I feel like Vine did
what it was here to do.
-It did. It did, man.
Rest in peace for now.
But, yeah, no, six seconds
is how I started.
And I was just making videos
in my set,
which was my living room,
which was my bathroom,
which was my car.
I was just screaming
in different areas of my house
for six seconds at a time.
And then I transitioned over
into YouTube
and started making character
and having fun on there.
-And so, with this idea
of not just Vine,
but then also YouTube,
was this something
that your parents
had any understanding of,
when you were telling them
"Hey, I'm doing this thing
six seconds at a time, and it'
going to make me a big star"
-Aw, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
I'm brown. [ Laughs ]
You thought I was Hasan Minhaj
coming back out here and wearing
a bun all of a sudden, yeah.
we got the whole family
on this episode.
No, but I...
[ Laughter ]
My dad was completely confused
by what I was doing online
Right?
-Uh-huh.
-I'm making videos.
There are strangers
following me.
There's a million stranger
Making videos?
That sounds mysterious.
So I had to clarify it
to my dad, right?
He sat me down,
looked at my phone,
and made me go through
and delete
every single one
of my followers.
Like, block each one
so they would stop following me,
because, what, like, he's trying
to protect me, right?
-Sure.
-Being secure.
But then my dad realized,
like, on a college tour,
as I was, ironically,
going and seeing a college
that another tour
was following me along
and was asking to, like,
take pictures of me.
And my dad realized that, "Oh,
my God, what's she's doing
is having an impact
on the world.
And she's doing
different things."
And so he basically allowed me
to continue making videos.
And he's the one --
my brown father --
who's made me academically focus
my entire life,
who made me delete followers
at one point,
who took away my phone,
because I wasn't studying
for the S.A.T., of course.
-Yeah.
-But I had an iPod
behind my mattress,
so I kept running the business
back there.
[ Laughter ]
-Kept making those videos, girl.
So, made me academically focus
my whole life.
And I ended up
moving out to L.A.
because of his blessing.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-Had the parent's support.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Had the parent's support.
-It is --
It's very nice to know now tha
even if he changes his mind,
you could never delete
25 million people.
[ Laughter ]
-Nah, it takes too much time
-Yeah, absolutely.
You just --
You're obviously
are close to your parents.
You just went to Italy
with your family.
-One word, four syllables,
Limoncello.
-All right.
-It was amazing.
-You like limoncello?
-Oh, I love limoncello.
It's too sweet, which is
how you know it's for me.
And they actually came
to our table.
And by "they," I mean a waiter
came to our table
to welcome us to Italy
and gave us like four
little shot glasses of this,
the nectar of the gods,
I refer to as limoncello.
And I mean, being, you know,
like a little frat boy
back in the day, I was like,
"Oh, sweet, a shot. Boo!"
[ Laughter ]
Tossed it back and was, like
I came back up,
and my parents are just sippin
very slowly, wide-eyed.
-Yeah.
-And I'm like, "What --
What are you guys --
what's going on?"
My face immediately
starts melting,
and I'm just feeling good,
blasted drunk
for the first time
with my parents.
It was awesome.
-Well, I don't know.
I think you might be
a lightweight
if it only took
one shot of limoncello.
-Oh, yeah. Teal cheap date
-Yeah, there you go.
-Real cheap.
[ Both laugh ]
-And so this is the second
season of your show.
Tell us a little bit about -
-Yeah.
-What -- Basically,
what's the plot of this?
-Sure. Okay.
So, if you don't know the show
it's basically diving
into the gig economy, right?
So, we are so lazy nowadays.
Like, this generation's insane
because we hire
personal assistants
through our phone.
Your Uber?
Honey, you ordering
your own personal driver.
That's what you're doing.
Uber, Lyft.
Postmates, you're ordering
people to come to your house
and give you these things
and get things done
so that you don't have to.
So, what's the story
behind that person?
What -- What's going on
in their life?
And how are they doing?
So, that's basically what Liza
is on "Liza on Demand."
Not too dissimilar to how
I started my job on my phone
But literally made a caree
from my fingertips,
from the palm of my hand.
-That's really cool.
And there's --
What's been fun to watch is,
you know, obviously,
you've taken
this very unconventional path.
And, yet, you've also
found your way
into sort of
more conventional things,
including, you got to work
the red carpet for the Met Ball.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Basically,
Anna Wintour saw you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sorry?
-Anna Wintour saw you
and was like --
-Anna Wintour not only saw me,
she called me cute, Seth.
-She called you cute.
And by the way,
you looked fantastic.
-Thank you!
-Look at that.
-Ah!
That's not
a Strawberry Shortcake.
That's Liza Koshy.
-That's Liza Koshy.
Hey, thank you so much for
making time for us tonight
Just a delight to talk to you.
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations on everything
Liza Koshy, everybody.